well this morning we're taking you on a
journey back in time you can discover
King Tut's tomb at the Luxor because
where else but a pyramid for Egypt
Candice Charles is live this morning at
the Luxor with a look into the Egyptian
past Candace good morning to you
good morning John good morning folks
you're absolutely right John this is the
perfect place to discover King Ted's
tomb and of course you can go along a
journey with archaeologists Howard
Carter discovered the tomb almost a
hundred years ago it was intact as well
which is not very common for these teams
it's really cool to be able to go
through this experience an immersive
experience by imagine of course I'm
joined by Mackenzie rollinson from
Imaginext positions as well now we
finally kind of made it towards the end
of the exhibit we've passed the tomb
sarcophagus and now we're at the one and
only death mask tell us a little bit
about it yes so you were in the death
mask room so this is right before the
very last piece this is the true
celebration this is probably perhaps
like the most I would say like
identifiable artifact of King Tut you'll
see it in several instances we use it a
ton But ultimately like it is something
to see this is what laid over for the
mummy itself so it's a pretty it's a
pretty amazing thing it's pretty intense
we talked a little bit about the music
and everything and we really take it to
a whole nother level with all of the the
components that are involved in this
experience and right after this you
actually get to go inside the experience
even more with a little bit of extra
technology tell us about that because
this is all the rage right that's right
so right after the dust mask you'll see
the celebration of the hundred years
right what we've done now to date from
an archaeologist standpoint and then
you'll enter our virtual reality
experience will you get to enter the
Tomb in that same format I mean it's a
pretty incredible thing to see now in
1922
100 years ago a long time ago but
doesn't seem that long ago right to be
able to have this celebration like this
and experience it how does it feel to be
able to be a part of that yet I think
that it's great to have been able to
bring discovering King Tut's tomb to not
only the Luxor but just to the
individuals here in Las Vegas I mean
this is the closest you're gonna get to
Egypt and seeing these artifacts in real
life awesome well thank you so much
Mackenzie for having us we got your
little sneak peek of course as always we
have you covered you can find out the
details about tickets which aren't too
expensive I hear they're starting at 30
bucks guys on our website 8newsnow.com
for now live from Luxor I'm Candace
Charles eating these now all right
Candace thank you very much